will can you hear us yeah all right
awesome how are you i'm doing well man
i'm getting ready to head back to school
here in like two weeks so i'm excited to
get out of the house
uh let's start just with um this whole
idea that
on-chain metrics and price had diverged
it seemed like the on-chain metrics were
really strong but price kept falling
uh over the last few weeks it now looks
like we kind of are getting them to
converge back
uh and the on-chain metrics are being
reflected in price how do you look at
that
yeah sure so you know for the most part
um
you know market price follows what the
uh underlying investor activity is is
doing on chain
uh but we do have these kind of more
rare occurrences where
price is doing one thing while on chain
is doing another um
and so like the most recent example of
this that i could think of before now
um was in late january and then before
that
um in late september after we had this
big
crash like 20 25 crash before we
ran on that big run up to 60k from 10k
um but yeah you get these you get these
rare occurrences where price is moving
against on chain
and the way i like to think this is like
the longer that that happens
when that information finally gets
priced into the market it's going to
have a greater effect
and so i think the fact that you've had
such a large divergence
especially over you know such a longer
period of time um you know
several more looking at almost like two
months now that this has been going on
um really two three weeks heavily but
the fact that there's such a strong
divergence between the two makes me
think that
once that information is finally priced
in there's going to be a huge
um effect on price so we've seen
nine daily green candles uh
what exactly does that mean like what
should people take away from that
yeah sure so um just like any market
bitcoin
um you know there's traders and traders
use candles
um and so for these candles you need to
have this
um you know a closing and opening for
for
a different time frame such as you know
the daily hourly
um if people even look at like minute
candles right like traders
that are in there like on those really
short time frames doing all that in and
out you know day trading stuff
um but you know bitcoin itself never
closes
so you know i a lot of people get upset
whenever you say oh bitcoins closing
what
because people are like oh well bitcoin
never closes but technically it does um
for trading purposes it does
and so bitcoin closes at uh i i just
know because i'm on easter time so
it's 8 p.m eastern time i think it says
zero utc
um and and so yeah so for for candles
you know
you you open and then you close and then
there's wicks
um and so the wicks are where the price
went above
or below the close um and so
you can you know there's traders that
literally analyze these these candles
and
and so they need some kind of um open
and closed threshold to be able to do
those analyzations
got it and so you created this 365 day
like stock rsi um over a 30-day net
change of illiquid supply
that is like an alphabet soup of things
to say explain what this metric is
and then um it looks like right now uh
it's starting to show some pretty
interesting things especially when you
compare it to what it's
shown us over the past yeah for sure
um the name is definitely a mouthful
like some of the stuff just sounds like
really complex it's really not um what
this basically is
is a way to kind of track the the
underlying
um supply shock in the market because in
my opinion that's
that's what drives bitcoin up to have
these big
price rallies is um you know you have
this
wave of supply shock and then the
speculators come in and ride that wave
up
and and you know take the reins of it
and and push it up further on the
speculative premium
um and so like when you go back and look
at bitcoin's history i also threw in uh
the newsletter we did this week an
example from
uh the you know 2017-2018 um
that time frame um and what you see is
kind of you know at the beginning of the
bull market
um you know well i should i should start
here at you know in the bear market
you have a capitulation event and then
going into the bull market
um you have the supply uh supply shock i
like to think of as a supply squeeze
kind of just because it sounds cooler
but that's what really propels us into
that main
phase of the bull market and then on the
back end of that
um you see you know supply becomes
liquid again
um and so for anybody who's not familiar
basically when
i'm saying a liquid or liquid um the way
you can think of this is like
um the the uh coins moving to like
entities on the blockchain that have a
very low or high
um spending behavior so liquid and
and glasnode also has something called
highly liquid which is like a way to
look at it even further
um have like extremely high spending
behaviors so these coins are in and out
all day
these are speculative traders right then
you have liquid coins which
are you know are in and out of fair
amount and then you have illiquid and a
liquid or the way i like to think of it
as the strong hands right
um these are the people that take in a
lot of coins
never really sell them these are the
long-term investors that are kind of the
the um you know concrete foundation of
of
of bitcoin so um you know kind of
analyzing their behavior i think has a
lot of signal to it
and you know these are the these um
indications
that that you get from this metric
aren't um you know
you don't get them often but when they
do come they have a
very high reliability and so what we
have now is you know we had this big
capitulation event in the end of may
a bunch of coins became liquid um that
were previously registered as strong
hands and and so
what you've had since then it's just
this really strong reaccumulation
and so like in this broader context a
broader context we've actually
reached um what i would have used for
this metric as
a buy signal where we fully made the
rounds from you know full capitulation
below this rsi
and now we're back above it so to me you
know just seeing not only that that
we're in a buy signal but
um the rate of change from that cell
from that capitulation to this new
to this new buy signal is just flash is
really is really
um you know quite incredible um going
going back in bitcoin's history we
haven't really
seen anything like this aggressive per
se like we absolutely you know obviously
like i said you know we see these supply
shocks every you know every full run
um but but nothing on on on
this scale of in terms of momentum even
even looking back to last year which was
you know is still still a really strong
wave but yeah
this has pretty much just been vertical
accumulation since may
and so when you look at things like
exchange balances it looks like again
uh people are buying bitcoin on the
exchanges and they're just
taking them off almost as fast as they
possibly can is that accurate
yeah um so the the exchange flows are
are something that i think a lot of
people are familiar with now um you know
the way that the premise here is that
you know when coins are being moved on
to exchanges
um they're being sold um you know when
they're being moved off exchanges
they're going into some kind of like
custodial service or cold storage not
you know to to be
held um and so this is something that
you know a lot of analysts have been
following for the for you know the early
mid part of this bull run
up until kind of mid april um you know
you just had
coins just getting ripped off of the
exchanges um and so
you know in in mid april all of a sudden
you had like you know between then and
and uh
and march i mean i'm sorry in uh may
19th you had like 145 000 coins that
came out to exchanges
and so you know that was obviously
highly bearish because you had a lot of
people moving those coins onto exchanges
to be sold so that was like kind of an
indication that
you know we were gonna need this kind of
prolonged um reaccumulation phase
because a lot of coins had been sold
um but since then since since may 19th
we've kind of just been um
grinding sideways bearish um well i
shouldn't say sideways
sideways down which is actually bullish
for this indicator because it's saying
the exchange balances are going down
um but this week we've got this really
large down drop
and anybody who is on twitter by the way
um might have seen yesterday that um
there were these huge reported outflows
and um i left that data out this this
data is only going up to thursday i left
the
i mean only up to wednesday i left the
thursday uh data out
just because um some some of those
transfers were internal it just hasn't
been picked up by last notes heuristics
yet
so i just you know wanted to just be on
the safe side and just leave that data
out but
um even even excluding that um which is
showing like
like a ridiculous you know uh signature
on the chart that's why i just left it
out because you know
there's no way that that that's true it
has to partially be internal
um you know it we're still seeing really
strong accumulation
in terms of the exchange flows as well
got it and so when you look at this
exchange flow bollinger bands
right basically what you're doing is
you're overlaying charts on top of each
other and then they're telling you
hey based on the historical context when
this happens it usually leads to
prices going up or down and it literally
flashes green or red
uh this bollinger band explain what this
is and then why is it flashing green
right now
yeah sure um so like traditionally
people use bollinger bands just to kind
of gauge
um well a to track volatility and then
also to see
you know in a general sense when when
prices are at the bottom of the bands
um you know prices are low when prices
are at the top of the bands prices are
high and then you can kind of build like
this general premise to make other like
trading decisions based off of that um
but you know
i i like i said you know i think the the
exchange balances um
the flows have some merit to them and i
wanted to kind of figure out how i could
kind of take it a step further
and so on glass node you can run
different technical indicators which
the bollinger bands are a technical
indicator um and so you know playing
around with them i
you know ran the bollinger bands over
them i found this interesting
um somewhat of a signal where you see
when when
this breaks below the bollinger band you
know what that's showing is like there's
super aggressive outflows um
you know that broke out of the band that
it's been you know that's been winding
in
um and so to me you know that that's a
bullish signal because
you know once again you're seeing heavy
accumulation you're seeing heavy buying
people are moving coins off exchanges
and so like going back and looking at
the sharp it's giving some really good
buy signals
um you know going back to like march
2020 but it's also given some some
pretty solid uh sell signals like you
know uh
in september before we had that big 20
25 crash
um and then also in late may before we
had the big capitulation
um and the way you know i'm saying a
sell signal is conversely to
you know the the metric going below the
bollinger bands it's when that when it
goes above so you know that's showing
really strong inflows to exchanges and
that's that's you know
presumed selling so when we look at the
net realized profit or loss basically
this idea of where people
uh if they were to sell today they would
make money to lose money
uh talk about where we are on this
because it was negative for quite a
while but now looks like we've gone into
uh into the positive again
yeah absolutely um so like a lot of the
coins that had been trading in the range
um and and this kind of goes um uh you
know along with what we were saying
about this whole re-accumulation phase
we're we're selling at a loss
so as people who bought at higher prices
we're selling at lower prices
um and so you know to me that was that
was just
once again evidence of the fact that it
was younger mark participants newer
market participants
um that were selling while you had these
strong hands that were coming in and
buying the coins
and were offsetting um you know the the
selling from those
from those weak hands and it was just a
matter of you know
when that when that process uh completed
but you know it looks like now after
trading in in uh you know
a long range of uh you know net loss is
being realized
we're actually starting to see net
profit being realized which is you know
which is of course a positive thing
because you know
investors aren't profit again um and so
you know they're more likely not to
um you know capitulate right so
the other way to the other way to think
about it is like you you don't want you
know as soon as we just start to have
you know
a bounce you don't want to just see
long-term investors that have been
holding off in this range just all of a
sudden start you know dumping their
coins
you know just looking for some kind of
exit liquidity um
and so to me like this is not alarming
necessarily but i just wanted to take it
a step further so like you had
you had two 2.4 billion dollars of
realized profit on tuesday
but i wanted to see you know is that
coming from people that had bought lower
in the range
right or is it coming from you know
longer-term investors that were just
looking for some kind of dead cat bounce
and
exit liquidity to you know move out and
then you know
they think that the market's bearish and
so of course you want to kind of follow
what the smart money is doing
and so just like looking into this a
step further looking at the average age
of the coins being sold
um you know that's that's still just
kind of sideways and the overall trend
of that is down so you know still
younger and younger coins overall being
sold
actually on tuesday when we had that
large um you know event of realized
profits
the average age of coins actually turned
it down so to me this is showing that
you know it's it it's people that bought
in this range i don't know maybe in
the low 30s right and and so they're now
kind of like pulling some chips off the
table
at the top of the range because we still
are technically um in this 30 40k range
um and then you know just to take it a
step further aside from just the average
age of the coins
you can actually look at by by age
cohort um you know how much selling has
come from the from those different ages
so like you know
uh an hour you can look at coins um you
know between seven and ten years between
a year and two years et cetera and so
looking at you know coins
between one week and three months we saw
this huge spike in that as well on
wednesday so
um you know obviously in the last three
months pretty much we've been in this
range
you know between between the last week
and three months so to me that that's
indicating as well that a lot of the
selling on tuesday was coming from
uh people in the range once again sopra
is something that we've talked about
non-stop remind people what sopra is and
then what you're seeing there
yeah um sober is actually like very
similar to that uh just like the way you
you get to it is different um
sober is the spent output profit ratio
so it's basically looking at the profit
of the coins that are trading on it
unlike on any given day
um and so what you want to see you know
in a bull market is that you know
obviously
coins are going to be trading in profit
and um whenever this
slightly dips below one which you know
below one coins are trading at a loss
on in aggregate right and that one that
you know it's just flat it's just
completely neutral
and like in a raging bull market this is
a good way to look at you know
the second it dips below one you know
those are really good buy opportunities
in a you know in a raging bull market of
course you need to look at other things
to
you know kind of build that premise that
you are the bull market because you know
you might
buy when it dips below one and you know
it's not a raging bull market and you
know it just
keeps going further down so that's one
way that like people i think
traditionally use sober in bull markets
and then conversely you can use it
in the bear market when you know you're
in a bear trend um
second that it goes above one um and you
know if you
you use other metrics that one's going
to determine you are in this bearish
market
um then you can use that to um you know
as kind of sell signals instead of buy
signals
in a bull market um but anyway so right
now we we've gone back above
back above one um and what i would like
to see here is us to
either a kind of like stabilize above
one
or b you know have have some kind of
price correction
um you know today we're down like two
percent i'd like to see you know like
some kind of like five ten percent plus
correction
um and for us to bounce off of one um
and to me that would that would be a
really good sign
uh you know that that we have you know
then we're back in a bull market before
i turn over to my brothers real quick
a couple questions uh what about miners
what are they doing are they in profit
are they not are they accumulating
selling
yeah this is um this is interesting
because uh you know miners
miners played a role in the capitulation
event that we had down in late may
um and you know probably part of the
reason why we kind of chopped around in
that range for a while and kind of was
moving
you know sideways bearish um but you
know for almost for almost two months
now
miners have actually been accumulating
and you know part of that is due to you
know we had this big drop in hash rate
and then you had this
massive like record difficulty
adjustment and so now the miners that
are still on the network are like
extremely profitable
um and so you know it you know it's just
from you know first principles it makes
absolute sense why you know you're
seeing this really strong accumulation
joe john what questions you guys got
will what's going on man
uh big fan of your work i only open up
his email the day that you write
appreciate it i got you uh i'm gonna go
over there and smack
that was a pretty good one it took me
like 30 minutes to think of that so uh
no so for people that don't look uh
don't necessarily have
a kind of background in financial
markets don't look at technical
indicators don't kind of look at any of
these on-chain metrics
but they own bitcoin they see it as
whether it's a store value or just part
of their long-term
holdings or financial strategy should
they be caring about on-chain metrics
are there certain things that they
should be looking at where do they start
is it important etc yeah absolutely
um you know i think there are some
people that just don't care right like
there's people that are just
i'm going to dca i'm not i don't care
about any charts or anything yeah
and these people are definitely out in
it you know out and spoken on twitter
um but you know i think on chain can be
useful to
um you know just kind of have some
directional awareness right like yeah
maybe you're not going to make a trading
decision based off of it but some people
just to you know like to enjoy
um you know knowing kind of where we are
in terms of
you know traditional market cycles or um
you know where what's the behavior of
the investors on you know just so they
can be
you know prepared and you know just
aware of where you know kind of where we
are
um and so you know i think for for just
people who are gonna huddle and just
you know they don't care about you know
you know price fluctuations i think
there there can still be some value for
them there
um and in terms of like how to how to
go about like learning on chain i you
know i think there's a couple good
newsletters um of course like i'm going
to show my own but
glass note also does like an excellent
newsletter um
willie wu does one as well but his is
fifty dollars well i think it's fifty
dollars a month
um but you know mine's free and
glassline is also free so for people who
are just like looking to just dip their
toes in the water
um i think those are two really good
options uh you know those go straight to
your email as well so
you know that's a good way to get
started also your glass node
on their website they have something
called glass node academy and it's just
you know it's completely free it's just
um basically like an introduction
program to kind of get
a you know good understanding of kind of
like the uh you know very entry level
metrics and things like that
will thank you for doing this um i also
enjoy your
letter every day when you write it i
make sure to like it as well um
i am curious what you like what you use
to look at on chain metrics what
services
um are out there available which ones do
you like which ones do not like
um and like is there anything people
should basically be looking at or
staying away from
yeah sure great question um you know i
think i think overall
um you know it's still a very um niche
like little little segment of even
bitcoin on the the whole on chain
uh analysis community so you know i
think i think the answering community
does a good job of kind of policing
itself where
people will call each other out for bad
work um and so look i
i don't think necessarily there's any
any providers that i would say to stay
away from
um you know i personally prefer glass
node just because
i think i think they have some really
interesting um data especially around
entities
i think um there's a lot of signal in in
their entity
data that this proprietary to them so i
see merit i see merit in them for that
reason
um but you know there's other really
good data providers out there including
uh
nick carter's coin metrics which i think
is probably one of the more popular ones
and then also crypto quant
which is based out of uh south korea so
um you know there's some other small and
upper
up and coming ones like bite tree i know
of they're based out of england and then
also uh whale map they do some really
interesting um unique data
you know kind of uh tracking whale
movements and uh
they've come up with some creative
metrics there so um yeah
you know it's still it's still a small
um
very very niche thing so yeah i think
overall like
it does a good job of kind of policing
itself
yeah appreciate that well when you think
about
uh what people should do with the
metrics i know that you and i have
talked about it before is this something
that you think
should just guide their overall view of
kind of the macro environment of bitcoin
do you think it's something that they
should be trading on
do you think that uh it's just kind of
one data point it's the bible and
of data points how do you think about it
yeah um you know the way i think about
on chain is it's best used to find
broader trends
you know you can look at on chain and
like you can watch like the intradaily
exchange flows and you can drive
yourself
absolutely crazy doing that like you
know i
i think the real value is following like
what's going on over multi
you know multi-week basis multi-month
basis you know where are we in terms of
um you know a broader sense and kind of
gain this kind of like
directional awareness and you know in
terms of um
you know how is the kind of like
underlying investor activity looking
because on-chain is basically like x-ray
vision of the market
um and you can see what all different
kind of entities are doing
by my age you know by their size if
they're exchanges if they're
you know retail whatever um and so like
i
i think that's that's the best way to
use it is as kind of like this
foundational premise in a broader sense
um and like if i was going to make any
trading you know decisions i would
use it that way but i also think you
know it should be used in confluence
with other things
you know i think um all good traders you
know look for confluence
across you know multiple different kinds
of indicators so you can use things like
technical analysis
you know order flow analysis follow
liquidity um you know
whatever it may be but i i just see on
chain even
even if you don't see it as like your
primary way to analyze the market
i still think it's a very strong um
supplemental
way to to analyze things and at least
kind of give you this like situational
awareness as to
you know okay yeah we're you know seeing
strong accumulation
we're still not in you know bear
territory
um and so you know i think you know uh
we're still
in this underlying bull market even
though price action is perhaps saying
another thing
or you can maybe you know use it to have
that foundational premise
and then use the technical analysis to
get more of kind of like a
accurate entry or you can use order book
flow analysis to get like him you know
more solid entry
um and so yeah i think it it's best to
use with other things right
and looking for confluence amongst you
know like as many things as possible if
you get
you get confluence amongst on-chain
technical analysis
and fundamental analysis and you know
whatever you're looking to like order
books and stuff
you know that that to me is like the
ultimate buy you know and and this is
what we had been tracking over the past
month is like
you had this confluence with volatility
where volatility was really tightening
up
you know it looked like volatility was
was getting ready for this massive move
um and at the same time we have we have
been tracking this you know
quote-unquote supply squeeze
um where we had more and more coins
getting re-accumulated
um you know by those strong hands from
from the speculative traders so
you know i think there were some there
was some synergy in that right where you
had
these uh this confluence across across
two different things and and
um you know i think those those are the
best opportunities
well you're a legend where can we send
people to find you on twitter or
subscribe to the email
yeah sure thanks for having me on pomp
this was this is really fun and uh it
was nice to meet your brothers as well
um i'm on twitter at w clementi iii
and then i have a newsletter that's free
goes out
every week and then you know sometimes
i'll send out an intra-weekly one if you
know if i
if i see something like super
interesting but it's it's wc3 i'm sorry
btc uh by wc3 at sub stack
dot com and it's also in my bio on my
twitter so you can just
click that people uh people in the
comments love you which means that uh
you're doing a great job so keep it up
uh i think that you're gonna end up
passing uh
joe and twitter followers by the end of
the year but that's just my thought
process
uh 275. oh he signs you up he said
what's joe had
he's like he's like i got a chance i
think you got a chance
well what are you killing it i think i'm
at uh
like 155 or one second he's at 156.
so uh last year joe was at zero will
what you you were at what at the
beginning of the year
uh like 2 000
000 to 155 in about six months joe you
went
from what at the beginning of the year
zero to two seconds no you didn't have
zero the beginning
oh i'm talking about last year uh i
don't know i'd have to check his growth
is more will's growth
that's the big uh that's the big
competition i want to see joe
monitare lebron james retweeting them
he's just
but will man will's got the beast the
apex predator
tailwind bitcoin community uh is a
little
more passionate than sports i think
sometimes hey some would argue that
bitcoin is uh better than new york
yankees but uh
that's all right well thanks for doing
this man
yeah no problem thanks so much guys
appreciate you talking buddy